the relationships that streamers have
with the games they play are a little
different than say yours or mine there
are individuals that fit certain games
like a glove i'm feeling an imposter
i've been waiting for this moment my
whole life toast
we're waiting so long for this
but there are also streamers whose
identities have been transformed by the
games they've discovered to the point
where the code and the person
almost become one inseparable entity bro
look at that it looks just like me
[Music]
of course becoming synonymous with a
single game can come with a lot of perks
like big fat paychecks larger than life
fame and a rabid following that will
watch you on your good days and your bad
ones i don't get nothing but you don't
get nothing nothing i got nothing
but as grateful as these personalities
might be to the games that helped launch
their stardom playing the same thing
over and over again
can become tiresome and if not addressed
that frustration
can quickly develop into resentment god
gaben you suck so much to make it video
games it
hurts me bro so the obvious solution to
saving one's sanity is to mix things up
and play something else
and the results for doing just that
can
really vary they can be good 30 bomb
baby maybe barcelona's right dude maybe
i am a top three warzone player they can
also be hilarious
oh it's a duck
it's a [ __ ] duck
or
they can be downright ugly cat blitz
quit the game you're trash you're awful
you're so
stupid but without a doubt the biggest
challenge that streamers face when
looking to freshen things up a little
bit
is the pushback they get
from their audience i can't tell you how
many times every time i kind of make a
major switch starting to play
counter-strike people came in dude
you're not playing call of duty anymore
whatever bro okay dude that game made
you this stream's gonna die now
counter-strike to overwatch dude that
game made you dude overwatch to fortnite
dude that game made you fortnight back
to call of duty dude that game made you
and now here we are playing some valor
and dude
however in the case of the ever badass
and munition streaming has never been
about bowing to the demands of anyone or
imprisoning herself and the polygonal
walls of a single game it's been about
what it should always be about having
fun this guy was typing up
he was typing a message
while most of us were introduced to anne
through her exploits playing rainbow six
siege over the last few years she's been
quietly carving out her own path playing
and doing whatever the hell she wants
oh
so how is it that this no-nonsense og
content creator has been able to
effortlessly direct her stream wherever
she wants it to go
without fear of the consequences what
inspired her to step away from the game
that for a while defined her and better
yet how did she become one of the
biggest and most beloved female
streamers on a notoriously toxic
platform
where does one send an application to be
your boyfriend oh right here
it's right here
[Music]
okay so before we dive into ann's story
i'm just gonna ask that you please like
the video subscribe to the channel and
turn on notifications also be sure to
check out our youtube shorts channel
from what i hear there's this dimitri
guy with some pretty sick clips up there
alright so if there is one thing you can
confidently say about ann munition it's
that she isn't afraid of expressing
herself whether that's in-game i can't
swim any faster than that
i am talking to you i'm gonna burn your
boat oh
oh god i didn't mean to drop it get off
the boat get off the boat get off the
boat get off the boat in real life it
happens all the time where like dudes
will crash their car and pubg
and then their whole community is just
like driving like a woman like why is it
my fault that this guy can't drive
[Laughter]
or interacting with chat if i was a
woman i would get 1 million viewers what
i have 1400 viewers right now also maybe
it's because i'm playing piano and you
have no actual talents oh and while most
of us might look at anne and think she's
this hardened unfazable twitch veteran
the truth is that she's not as tough as
she might appear and then as i updated
it and of course you know every day
and my pc froze i'd restart my pc so all
joking aside anne's journey as a gamer
began with her siblings playing super
nintendo games like super mario world
and paperboy but as she grew older and
was drawn to fps games like goldeneye
turok and eventually halo but gaming
wasn't ann's only interest she got into
cars music event photography and graphic
design which eventually she turned into
a full-time career it was around then
that ann started dipping her toes into
content creation on youtube where she
uploaded reaction videos as she played
through scary games like outlast but
once ann discovered her interest in live
streaming
she decided to try it out for herself it
just seemed like it was something really
fun and like a cool way to connect with
people so i started doing it in my free
time after work and from there it just
kind of took off after making the jump
from console to pc anne officially
launched her twitch channel in june of
2014. now in the beginning she streamed
games like minecraft but being that she
was still finding her footing on the
platform she wasn't really tied to any
specific game and she was just having
fun
yay doors open
wait
look at this one
a little bit oh jesus did i put armor on
oh my god oh my god no run i can't oh my
god are you joking why did i put armor
on no
no i put on armor
why didn't i put on armor
in the span of one year anne's twitch
channel had grown to the point that she
was able to turn it from a hobby
into her new career now a choice to
stream full time came with some pretty
big perks but as ann began to realize it
also came at a cost socially i was
willing to sacrifice things like hanging
out with my friends all the time or
going out all the time
or you know just
generally having more free time in order
to commit to growing my channel of
course there were also challenges she
faced that went beyond time constraints
you see as anne became more comfortable
in her new streamer life she also began
to pull the curtain back on her personal
one and while most of her viewers openly
embraced her for who she was as a
multi-racial openly gay female streamer
she has unfortunately had to deal with
her fair share of [ __ ] i think it
depends on what i'm wearing too
wearing like like this like a snapback
and then they're like lesbian alert
yes yeah i could i can see that i mean
brandon
swamp creatures in chat aside
streaming wasn't all that bad for him
her genuine enjoyment of what she was
doing drew more and more people to her
stream and in 2017 she was approached by
ubisoft with a sponsorship to play
rainbow six siege i still have the email
where i told them i
don't know how to play this game and i
will probably be terrible at it
and they were like that's fine you know
we just want to showcase people of all
different skill levels so it's totally
cool if you're brand new
and i think i tried to kill the hostage
like a bunch of times i mean not on
purpose but um i was just really bad at
the game in spite of her initial
reservations as anne spent more time
playing and getting better at siege she
began to establish herself as one of the
game's most recognizable and watchable
personalities thanks in large part to
her sense of humor
[Music]
i just hacked my way into the objective
what
and her ability to clap cheeks
one friendly remaining what
one
someone can hire me to be a pro siege
player
after years of playing whatever she
wanted anne had finally found her bread
and butter game one that she not only
loved but was able to consistently
attract eyeballs to her stream with and
her increasing popularity playing siege
led to more opportunities for anne she
found herself rubbing elbows with
celebrities got sponsored by red bull
made appearances on the news and was
even honored with her very own in-game
charm but as charmed as siege was by
anne she found herself growing
increasingly exasperated by certain
aspects of the game it could be kind of
frustrating i think the more success you
have on twitch the more you have to deal
with people who are stream sniping and
people who are actively trying to make
the game not fun for you and that's
gotten way worse in the past few months
especially i've noticed a lot more
people who are stream sniping and
it can be very very difficult to want to
play siege when you know that that's
gonna happen every day
on top of all that if her pre-siege days
were anything to go by and never wanted
to be a slave to any single title and as
scary as abandoning your channel's
primary draw can be
and decided to go for it diving
headfirst into the strange and wonderful
world of other games and fortunately
her fans were down for the ride oh it's
getting faster i can feel it
oh no
i fell it gets so fast no no no pick up
the gun pick up the gun you eat it no no
hang on
hang on hang on hang on
hang on hang on hang on
okay we're good
oh that's barbed wire
i was i was trying to copy what you were
doing and i was like sidestepping
of course ian has always favored the art
of clicking heads so you're likely to
see her still indulging that in escape
from tarkov but part of her stream's
appeal is that you never quite know what
you're gonna be watching and honestly
that's the best part about anne's
success it wasn't planned or contrived
she simply did what she enjoyed to the
best of her ability and by consistently
staying at the helm of her career and
dominating the games she played instead
of letting them dominate her found
herself living the proverbial dream i
feel like i started streaming and there
was it was just kind of surprise after
surprise where it was like oh i can quit
my job and stream video games cool like
okay oh you want me to meet tony hawk
okay cool weird for playing video games
this is strange you know i'm going to
the white house weird just like you know
sorry miniplexes by trusting her gut
when it came to making moves ann was
essentially able to achieve the ultimate
goal of content creators the world over
find a game you love build up your army
of loyal supporters
and have them follow you wherever you
choose to go honestly i think that kind
people
surround other kind people and if you
have a positive community then you're
going to draw in more people who want
that experience on twitch
i know that there's many large
communities that are just
spam fests and can be kind of toxic
toward the streamer and that's not
necessarily a bad thing if that's what
the streamer is okay with and that's
what they want for their community
i personally prefer if i can have a bit
more of a tight-knit community and
people who like to spend time with each
other and remember each other's names
and and that kind of thing i think it's
a nice feeling and it makes me excited
to stream every day and the level of
respect and comfort shared between anne
and her audience has further inspired
her to expand her streaming beyond just
gaming recently she's tried her hand at
more just chatting and irl streams too
giving a wider window into her personal
life than she may have dared two years
ago at the end of the day whether she
intended to or not and has become a
shining example for young female gamers
who are interested in giving streaming a
try she hasn't shied away from the
challenge of games that are either
intimidating or infuriating and she's
overcome adversity in many forms while
remaining unashamedly herself
reinforcing the idea that gaming
is for everyone regardless of sex race
or orientation and no matter what comes
her way next if ann's journey has taught
us all anything it's that marching to
the beat of your own drum is just always
the better option
one enemy remaining us
message
tim is like the only big time streamer
like big time like top 10 twitch that i
just love i
loved him i will always loved him
bro that game made you
bro i can't wait till the stream dies
can't wait i will say though and maybe
like i'll give it give it another shake
i know everyone on twitch is playing new
world right now this game sucks